what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrys so before we hop
into this video I wanted to instantly
give a shout out to today's video
sponsor we've worked for them before
they're great people
Vikings War of clans thank you guys for
sponsoring this video that's right if
you haven't heard a shout amount before
war of clans as a game inspired by the
classic RPGs and strategy games of the
90s and early 2000s we grew up on that
stuff stuff like diablo dragon warrior
old-school fallout etc train your
Vikings build up armies and villages and
do battle with literally millions of
other players online some of these
events pack in over three million
players at a time you can literally form
your own independent inside of the game
play for five minutes play for five
hours play for five days with no food or
bathroom breaks play water use in the
bathroom that's most likely what I'm
gonna do it's up to you so if you'll
want to support our channel and get
started on a badass Viking clan of your
very own hit up our special link in the
description box to download Vikings War
of clans for free for Android and iOS
and if you do you'll get a special bonus
of 200 gold coins plus a protective
shield to set you on the path of badass
hurry and don't forget to look us up at
reject nation so you can join the
official House reject clan that's right
we're that cool we got our own viking
clan that's right we're men now on to
the video you clicked on here for check
out the Charlie's Angels trailer frame
now
[Music]
I didn't do anything just because they
can I'm the power industries but there's
a possibility it can be weaponized
[Music]
- angel who are you
three possibly we exist because
traditional law enforcement can't keep
lady spies dates for mi6 Oh God did you
just spend my compressed is corrupted
and deoxygenation his brainstem that
sounds beautiful
don't worry he's gonna wake up
[Music]
there's another closet some of these
[Music]
how's it look like it felt really good
[Music]
that's the ending shot of the movie
[Music]
she wrote and directed this - okay I did
she directed no she wrote it as well
yeah Elizabeth Banks man rising beyond
the pitch-perfect world into the world
of action espionage banking it
yeah with a lot of inspiration from
Mission Impossible apparently it's very
apparent yeah so much Mission Impossible
in here I'll tell you what I'm excited
for John Djimon Honsou Patrick Stewart
and Noah sent to neo other than that I'm
sick of reboots and throwing feminism in
my face dude you miss Jonathan Tucker -
miss Jonathan Tucker gosh got to
recognize the Menace
how dare they include another Bosley in
the form of a woman
what the hell and why are there three
women in here you know I think they are
yes they are really remake Charlie's
Angels with all dudes to even the
playing field everybody's been waiting
for all this time honest sincere note I
like the trailer I was actually like a
little skeptical about this I felt like
if you're gonna reboot Charlie's Angels
at this point you really need to do
something that feels very different this
is captured in a way that I don't know
if it's like oh this is more appealing
to women than it is to men I can't speak
for women mm-hmm even though I'm quite
the ladies man
all the women will testify especially
the four leads in this film what I like
about it is the Mick G person and you
know I haven't actually seen a lot of
this show I've maybe seen an episode or
two I've see more like clips and
segments about it it always seemed like
there was hot women targeted for male
demographic that's sort of the vibe I
always got it's a product of an older
time even though I didn't enjoy the Mick
G movies for the cheesy films that they
were just how constantly super sexy they
were they even become part of the
Pussycat Dolls yeah those were very much
marketed towards like let's get like
horny guys and the theater here to watch
these like how three chicks kick some
ass you know watching this like I guess
I don't know if this is something that's
like oh this is designed to be
we're appealing the woman but this seems
a little bit more universally appealing
where I think men and women can both
actually enjoy this and and perhaps it's
captured in a way - it is a little bit
more empowering for women mm-hmm I hope
so you should be reconsidering that I
figured to reboot this in this day and
age and you got Elizabeth Banks behind
the screenplay and directing it I have
confidence they could do it I'd be a
little more skeptical if it was you know
a man directing and honestly well yeah I
mean in this day and age one of the
things towards representation is that
you know there's not as much behind the
camera either I mean there's a lot made
out of casting representation but I
think for Charlie's Angels for reboot
like this a female voice behind the
camera is a great pretty essential idea
I mean you know I imagine I don't know
who created the original show but I'm
excited for ya what this is overall and
the only thing I would want maybe from a
second trailer is a little more
breathing space to just get the three of
their chemistry like the three core
angels of this room because there's a
very edited trailer it's all it's just
like we're showing a lot of little clip
ins and a lot of the set up and and you
know the first taste of everything well
let's do a Sony Pictures whenever they
do these reboots you know the
Ghostbusters and men and black there's
something about the energy that there
seem to throw a lot into trailers but
the energy feels a little bit toned down
I'm not sure how the actual scenes in
the movie will play I feel like with
Elizabeth Banks though know for someone
who has the comedic Sensibility she has
and really understands the importance of
rhythm and energy I feel like though
I'll have this clear sense of energy and
probably have some really good
characters there what we're seeing with
the three leads like Naomi Skye Kristen
Stewart Ella Helens good I agree I want
to see a little bit more of their
chemistry they actually seem like
characters yeah host:3 hot girls
swooning over dudes no image and I
really like yes that does have its you
know spy espionage mission impossible'
aesthetic that it seems to be borrowing
from but that's appropriate I feel like
that works wasn't for this franchise I
mean it's already
kind of out there espionage story anyway
you're getting like the multiple
costumes instead yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think this is actually a pretty cool
niche and I like the way that they've
apparently decided to expand the
mythology and encapsulate both the old
TV show and the McGee movies I get
almost like a Kingsman vibe because they
said they want to have like units of
angels alright world and Bosley is a
rank that different people hold and
stuff and I guess maybe there's one
Charlie or something like that but I
feel like this could be a neat
opportunity to grow what the show is
instead of just being nostalgic about it
too there was multiple Charlie's would
have been Charlie's ' after the end yeah
that's true what it yeah yeah I am
multiple Charlie that's how it works in
the English as Esav of the plural and
makes a lot of sense saving the world
one grammatical at a time they seem like
smart tough women who are also really
hot I mean usually I get like they are
smart but they always leave wood like
sexy first and the seduction is often an
element a seem to be leading a lot with
you know brains and personality first in
which I which I like about them know how
and there are different roles as a unit
as a team and seriously I'm excited for
uh super DiNozzo I mean in a female led
movie than you're like know which dudes
get invited into the girls club now I
feel like that's a fun by-product
instead of you know women getting to sit
around going maybe one of us is gonna
make it into the movie you know like
Naomi Scott looks like she's gonna do a
great job here from Power Rangers -
Aladdin - this it's like three very
different characters and Kristen Stewart
I'm hoping we get to see a lot more for
a comedic side here she looks like he's
having a great time she looks like
having a really fun time she's really
Sun those action moments - I'm not
really familiar with Ellen
generous generous she's great comedian I
love her show yeah hello let's go I'm
not really familiar with her word she
looks like a total bad at me I don't
remember release date I feel like
they're pretty confident about this film
and maybe hey if we're lucky you know we
can get a crossover with Mission
Impossible get Ethan Hunt in there the
next time you know lead the Angels yeah
would that make that matter
awesome for everyone all right guys well
did you like this new Charlie's Angels
reboot trailer comment below subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification belt and then a lot of ways
that matters more if you subscribe click
that Bell don't forget to download
Vikings war of clans actually want a
hecka that's the one join our clan yep